jason bateman dishes on rumored new  couple Katy Perry and Orlando Bloom Katy  in Orlando have been gettin pretty cozy  lately recently spotted together dining  at the sunset tower with jen aniston and  jason bateman EG caught up with Bateman  who dish albeit briefly about the  rumored new couple every love the photo  with you and katy perry and orlando  bloom at the birthday celebratio yeah  and we want it's our favorite couple  over Eddie t so how do you like them  together they are fun playing it coy  fair enough Jason the father of two is  excited though about lending his voice  and Disney's Zootopia flash flash under  yard dash buddy it's nice to see you but  do his daughters know it's dad up there  uh well the nine-year-olds bright enough  to thank God to sort of put these things  together the four-year-old is is  understandably still dumb enough to not  really get it and that's where I want to  keep her